in state government and who has been
involved in this special effort from day
one to my immediate right dr. Jim
mellitus technically a doctor but not
like a medical doctor but still a doctor
to my left governor Cathy Hoke Oh My
partner in state government who has been
a true treasure to the people of the
state of New York and to Cathy Howe
close left dr. Kent
Candace Johnson from Roswell Park Cancer
Institute which is where we are today
in Buffalo Roswell Park is one of the
leading cancer institutes in the United
States and a real jewel for the state of
New York and I thank her very much for
their hospitality today let me give you
some of the facts today one of the
points we want to make today is we're in
western New York Buffalo we've been
talking a lot about New York City in the
situation in New York City in Long
Island and Westchester and Rockland the
suburbs of New York City but just as
we're seeing of course the country
this virus presents a slightly different
problem in different parts of the
country it also presents a different
problem in different parts of the state
overall the total hospitalizations are
basically flat from where they were
yesterday and as you see the overall
curve is on the way down and that is
good news certainly the net change in
hospitalizations is down not just down
as much as we would like
changing intubation ziz down and that's
always good news because intubations
means the person is on a ventilator 80
percent of the time when people are on a
ventilator they don't come off the
ventilator in a successful way the
number of new people in the state who
walked in the door yesterday or were
diagnosed with kovat is 1,300 that is
down and that's good news relative to
really bad
which is what was happening up until
then right we have to remember remember
our calculus of good definition of good
has changed here good is now not
terrible but on a on an absolute scale
1300 people walk in the door with kovat
on a single day in the state of New York
that would not be good news in any other
context between the sides of context
we're living in this is Erie County
Buffalo's in Erie County New York and
you see the numbers we had a dramatic
increase in Erie County and then
basically a leveling flat little uptick
yesterday number of total
hospitalizations in Erie three-day
average again basically flat these
numbers I will not take any of these
one-day numbers even three-day numbers
as absolute this is a new reporting
mechanism that just was put in place so
from a statistical point of view I don't
know exactly what the margin of error is
with all due respect to the great
statisticians doing this we've been
watching this spread all across the
state because this is like stamping out
a brushfire you need to run to where the
fire is and put it out there so we were
watching for a spread of the fire from
downstate New York towards upstate
whenever we see a small fire starting we
jump on it right away
testing isolation etc but that's
remained fairly constant and that's also
good news but the point that different
regions of the country have different
quote-unquote curves the virus does not
hit at the same time at the same rate so
you hear about different states in the
in the country and when they're going to
hit their apex when they're going to hit
their top and when they're going to come
down it's different all across the
country it's also different across the
state we've been talking about states
like there
uniform homogeneous entities some are
more homogeneous than others when I was
in the federal government i worked in
every state so you have a whole
different variety of states this state
we have very different regions within
New York when you say New York people
think in New York City yeah one of the
densest places on the globe
you also have upstate New York where in
some counties you have more cows than
people you know people don't think of
New York that way so as you see variety
across the country we have variety
across the state of New York and you
have to watch each one of those
individual curves and when does that
region hit a high point and where is
that because depending on that region's
curve is how you have to calculate your
strategy and you're looking at those
curves how long is the ascent up the
mountain and then how long are we on
that Plateau and then how long is the
descent from the plateau western New
York I believe were on the plateau all
right now the question is how long are
we on that plateau and is it a plateau
or might it still ascend downstate New
York
it appears that were on the descent and
the question then becomes in downstate
New York
well how quickly do we descend the worst
news and the really ugliest part of my
job these days is telling New Yorkers
this news in Erie County
we lost seven hospital deaths yesterday
for a total of 125 in the state we lost
481 people 452 in hospitals 29 in
nursing homes again nursing homes are a
central focus and priority for all of us
going through that
where are we today we're operating with
two rules first rule is do no harm
second rule is start to plan the
reopening planning the reopening is just
that plan the reopening understand that
calculated calibrated nobody's ever done
it before how do you do it when do you
do it but first rule do no harm we paid
a tremendous price to get where we are
today
and make the progress that we have made
today we may paid a tremendous price to
control this beast we closed down
everything people have worked tirelessly
in the health care system and the first
responders and the essential workers you
showed you can control the beast do no
harm
don't go backwards that's the first
point and then plan the reopening on the
do no harm you take a place like Erie
County any region in the country or in a
state that is still on the ascent or on
the plateau
beware of a hot spot beware of an
increased need in this state what we've
said is any need anywhere in this state
the rest of the state will surge
capacity and equipment and energy to
help that part of the state
so when downstate New York needed help
upstate New York was there
if upstate New York needs help or
Western New York needs help our central
New Yorker the north country needs help
the rest of the state will be there and
you have my word on that you know and
these crises pressure brings out the
best in the worse than people
I believe that individually you get to
really see how a person's respond the
response at a time of crisis you get a
little snapshot of their character and
of their foundation it's also true of
the collective it's also true of society
and when I say we have to move to help
western New York yeah there will be some
places in the state
we you hear a voice that says no no we
have to worry about ourselves we have to
take care of us and they're on their own
the way we're on our own
not in New York that's not how we
operate nobody's on their own we are one
state we are one family we are one
community and we're there to help one
another
so whatever Erie County needs whatever
was the New York needs you have my word
that the rest of the state will be
responsive hopefully we're on this
plateau and on the other side of the
plateau is a descent so we can manage it
but if it's not a descent and it's an
ascent anywhere in the state the rest of
the state will be there and part of it
is testing testing testing I know it's a
a granular topic but it's important
we're also going to have a a regional
calibration that we're going to make on
hospitals you have many hospitals that
are very quiet some hospitals are
actually laying off people believe it or
not in the middle of this because they
have no patients we are going to we we
artificially stopped the number of
patients going to into a hospital
because we ended what's called elective
surgery elective treatment and therefore
people can't go into the hospital for an
elective procedure in those parts of the
state and in those hospitals where the
hospitals are laying off people because
they're so quiet and they have that
capacity and capacity for the virus is
not an issue we're going to allow
elective outpatient treatment which
means the number of beds remain
available because the the number of
people using those beds is still
relatively minimal and we're going to
allow it in those hospitals and counties
in the state that do not have a covet
issue or we couldn't need their beds in
case of a surge
this will not include Westchester
Rockland New York City hospitals etc
because we have a real covert problem
there a woman cloak include Erie County
or Albany County or Dutchess and several
other counties where we still need to
protect those hospital beds in case we
need them for covert on testing people
need to understand this issue because
it's going to be determinative and it's
complicated and it's been somewhat
politicized and now you hear different
arguments about testing here are the
simple facts on testing and again
testing is something that no one would
have expected as an issue right testing
we do in this country and nobody really
noticed we have all system it's a
private-sector system and when you went
to the hospital and the doctor said you
have to have your child checked for this
so you have to be checked for this you
go to a lab you have your blood tested
that was the testing system no one ever
imagined this testing system was going
to become hyper relevant to survival and
would need a capacity of 20 30 40 50
times what the system was doing so this
came out of the blue in many ways and
it's one of the lessons we will learn
but for us who came out of the blue how
does it work
you have national companies that are
private manufacturers of laboratory
equipment and their piece of equipment
can operate their test kits okay and
there are a number of these private
sector companies and they make a machine
they sell that machine to labs a network
of labs all across the nation we have
about 211 labs in New York State they
buy these machines from these national
companies and they then have that
machine
sometimes they buy a number of machines
from different manufacturers and now
they have a number of different machines
some have higher output some have lower
output but each one requires that you go
back to that manufacturer to get a test
kissed test kit and reagent that works
for that manufacturers machine okay so
it gets very complicated quickly there
are different what they call reagents
chemicals that you need for each
manufacturers test kit and each
manufacturers machine and the big labs
will have bought a number of different
machines from a number of different
manufacturers ok so these are some of
the big manufacturers not all of them
you hear about Abbott which has a new
fast test and these are all these
companies are all working to come up
with these tests now and who's faster
and who's quick they're one-hour test 20
minute test 15 minute test 5 minute test
but every one of those manufacturers you
need to have their test kit and their
reagents to operate on their machine and
you have some labs that have five or six
different manufacturers machines when
you go to the manufacturers and you say
I need you to increase capacity many of
the manufacturers are saying I can't I
can't get enough reagents I can't get
enough
swabs these cotton swabs I can't get
enough vials I just don't have enough
material for my own test kits that's the
determiner of testing capacity okay and
you're asking a system that let's say
did let's say normally did 1000 tests
you're asking a system that 1000 tests
by the way I need 50000 tests so they
didn't anticipate this volume
and some of these manufacturers will say
look I have a supply chain that is an
international supply chain I get my
chemicals from China I get my chemicals
from here so that ability to ramp up is
what we're all struggling with and every
state is in charge of administering
testing because the 200 labs in New York
State are regulated by New York State I
regulate the 200 labs it's only
appropriate that the state should be in
charge of actual testing in the state I
agree with the federal government's
position on that I have 200 labs I
should come up with the system that says
how many tests in Buffalo how many tests
in Albany how many tests in Manhattan
how many tests in Long Island that's my
business I should be held responsible I
should be held responsible for making
sure those 200 labs actually deploy
across the state in a smart way hold me
responsible where it gets hard is when
the labs that I regulate say the
manufacturers of the problem and then I
call the manufacturers and the
manufacturers say I can't do it because
it's an international problem that's
where we are now last night I get home I
my three daughters with me now which is
a joy 99.9% of the time we're sitting
there we're watching the news Governor
Larry Hogan comes on the news great guy
governor of Maryland Republican chairman
of the NGA National Governors
Association of vice chairman so I work
with the governor and governor Hogan
says I bought five hundred test kits
from South Korea and there's a picture
of Governor Hogan at the airport
South Korea airliner and Governor Hogan
says I got 500 test kids from South
Korea and my daughter turns to me and
looks at me and says wow that was really
smart and she just looks at me
doesn't say anything else she didn't
have to
than media wave of guilt descend upon me
one of my other daughters was a little
more pointed in life little more literal
literal said why didn't you think of
that dad why didn't you think of buying
test kids from South Korea so now I was
really just feeling the minimus as a
governor Larry Hogan is a better
governor why didn't I think of buying
test kids from South Korea why didn't I
think of buying test kids from Korea why
didn't from China it's not what states
normally responsible for god bless Larry
Hogan he he really thought outside the
box and was very creative but that piece
is where the federal government can help
us take that national manufacturer and
that supply chain for the national
manufacturers and let the federal
government figure out South Korea and
China and international supply issues
rather than have 50 states now figure
out how to go be like governor Hogan and
figure out how to buy tests in South
Korea that's where the federal
government should help and that's the
that's the intelligent distribution of
responsibility on testing so the federal
government's right the states should
take the lead yes partnership federal
government you have to help us with this
national manufacturer in the supply list
after you do the testing states have a
second big test put together an army of
tracers who then trace each person who
tested positive who did they contact and
then isolate those people who you
contact also talking about reopening
we're gonna make reopening decisions on
a regional basis based on that region's
facts and circumstances about the covert
virus in other words just like some
states will reopen before other states
because they have a different
circumstance when it comes to Co vid and
their status with kovat it's
so true across the state North Country
has a totally different situation than
New York City
central New York is a different
situation we operate as one state but we
also have to understand variations and
you do want to get this economy open as
soon as possible and if a situation is
radically different in one part of the
state then another part of the state
take that into consideration and that's
what we're going to be doing so the the
same logic that applies to the country
applies to some states this state where
you have those varieties across the
state and we need to take that into
consideration so the way we've been
working on the economy in general across
the state where we recognized there's
one state yes but there are regional
economies within the state and we've
been working with each individual
regional economy will do the same thing
on this phase let's talk about reopening
economies in that regional context and
coordinated regionally and that's what
we're going to be doing and again I've
said this statewide but I want all our
regional partners to hear us let's not
talk about just reopening let's not have
gone all through this and all we're
going to do is go back to where we were
how do you use this as an opportunity to
learn the lessons and to build back
better that's what we have to do for
western New York we have my partner
lieutenant governor Kathy local who as
everybody knows is from Buffalo we're
going to ask her to take charge of the
western New York monitor the public
health issues make sure if we if there's
a problem in terms of Public Health
we're marshalling all the resources from
across the state to help West in New
York and also to start to work on the
reimagining and the reopening plan
for Western New York we're also going to
ask Bob Duffy who worked with me in the
state to volunteer to be a special
advisor to coordinate Public Health and
reopening in the Finger Lakes the
Rochester area last point we've gotten
through difficult situations before
western New York we went through seven
feet of snow a couple of years ago that
was fun we learned from that the state
we went through 9/11 which was a
crushing experience but we learned from
that and where we're different and we're
better we went through superstorm sandy
and we are the better for that and we're
going to be the better for this I
believe that it's the hard times in life
that actually make you better and make
you who you are if you're intelligent
enough to learn from them and to get the
message from them and that's what we
have to do here we have to do it
individually we have to do it
collectively what did we learn about
ourselves about the world about the
country from this period that we're in
and you get knocked on your rear end in
life yeah that happens you get nothing
on your rear end that's going to happen
the question is do you get up and if you
get up what type of person are you
and did you learn from getting knocked
on your rear end sometimes you get
knocked on your rear end and you have
nothing to blame things happen in life
health issues happen bankruptcies happen
things happen you get knocked on your
rear end okay get up get up have the
strength to get up have the wisdom to
learn from the experience and be a
better person for it Michael Jordan
documentary is on TV I'm a big Michael
Jordan fan
he doesn't make the varsity team Michael
Jordan bad coach maybe but he got
knocked on his rear end he was
disappointed what'd he do he worked he
worked harder
practiced more Michael Jordan Michael
Jordan wasn't just born you know God
didn't say here he is he made himself
the great player that he is and New York
we make ourselves this no nation we make
ourselves world war one world war two
the Great Depression some of the most
tragic situations actually forge the
character and the resolve of this nation
New York State the same thing and we
have to be smart enough to do the same
thing here and we will because we're New
York tough but not just tough it's easy
to be tough it's hard to be smart and
disciplined and unified and loving
that's what's harder and being tough but
we're all of the above that's why we're
special let's take a few questions I
have to go down to Washington and the
everything is a little tight from a
scheduling point of view today sir I'm a
White House visit what do you see the
focus being will it be a discussion
about reopening with the president what
will the focus of that visit be testing
and what does testing mean and how do we
do it and how can the federal government
work in partnership with the states just
basically because this is all new and
look it's a situation that is very
difficult and it is a situation where
however you do it it's gonna be a blame
game afterwards I heard the president is
briefing the other days right this is
one of those thankless tasks trust me it
is one of those tasks where when you get
to the end of it everybody's going to be
able to say you didn't do enough you
didn't do enough you didn't do enough so
I get the instinct to distance yourself
from it right but it is a situation
where you
need everybody to work together and you
need to understand quickly who's in a
better position to do what from my point
of view I think the federal government
has to take that national manufacture or
supply chain issue
god bless governor Hogan but you
shouldn't expect all these governor's to
go run around and do an international
supply chain while they're trying to put
together their testing protocol in their
state coordinating their labs how many
tests in Buffalo how many tests in
Albany then I have to put together an
army of tracers that's thousands of
people it's never been done before I'll
take all of that just don't give me
guilt and make me look bad to my family
in my state when governor Hogan goes to
South Korea and buys all the test kits
regards to reopening the state that
seems to be tethered to testing until
yesterday
symptomatic smear lis symptomatic folks
couldn't get a prescription to get a
test in western New York what can the
state do in the short term understanding
you need federal government's help but
what can the state do in the short run
to ramp up testing here because this is
an area that's like behind yeah we are
testing as a state just so you know
we're testing more than any state in the
United States a multiple of other states
more testing per capita than any country
on the globe that's what we're doing in
New York so we are doing more faster
than anyone else I get the New York
attitude I don't care that's not enough
I get it we have to do better we have to
do more and we need more tests and
that's what we are talking about here
the testing will educate you as you're
making your transition to reopening
right how do you get across the swamp
stone to stone across the morass stone
to stone across the morass one step at a
time and make sure you're on firm
footing and then you look for the next
stone then you look for the next stone
then you look for the next stone the
testing tells you where the stones
and the testing tells you when to pause
and that's why you need the testing you
need more testing in western New York
yes you need more in Rochester Syracuse
Albany north country southern tier and
New York City and Long Island we needed
more all across the board that's why I'm
going to Washington mr. McCarthy when
you head down to the White House today
I think it's been fair to say that
you've had to walk a fine line in your
dealings with him there's criticism that
you have and there's a phrase that you
have for him so I was just going to
continue when you can when you meet with
him today how you gonna handle this life
is a fine line life is a fine line being
in government is a fine line everything
is a fine line I tell you how I
negotiate the fine line you tell the
truth just tell the truth and I said to
the president that to the president from
day one and by the way he's done the
same piece of I mean he has no problem
telling me when he disagrees and he
tells me when he agrees I have no
problem telling him when I disagree and
when I agree so fine line and you can
try to figure it out or you know what
heck with it just tell the truth
and whatever it is it is you know I
think there's a there's been a lot of
discussion about testing but I don't
know that people have really I think in
many ways we're talking past each other
I understand the federal government's
point that it's up to the states and I
believe it is largely up to the states
but then even the federal government
will stand there and do a whole
presentation on what they're doing on
testing so then it's not really up to
the states if the FEMA people get up
there and an Admiral gets up there and
talks about what they're doing on
testing all right so then let's just
coordinate who does what what did the
states do what does the federal
government do what do you do and what do
I do I'll do whatever I'm supposed to
supposed to do just tell me what I do
and what are you going to do and I'm
going to ask them
to take this piece of this national
manufacturers getting the test kits in
the vials and the cotton swabs and the
chemicals and if they get that done for
the national manufacturers and then the
national manufacturers can feed my 211
labs then the states can take it from
there joining us there's continued
frustration over unemployment we have
folks calling emailing daily saying that
72-hour window where they were promised
a phone call back has come and gone
what can you sit to say to that you know
to ease their their frustration and
what's being done to smooth the process
yeah this is their right they are ready
I'll tell you the bad news and the good
news the bad news is there were so many
unemployment claims that it has
collapsed the unemployment department's
system their website system their phone
system we have 1,000 people who are now
working on that unemployment website and
phone call system I mean it's
unbelievable
a thousand people just to take the
incoming unemployment calls that's how
high the volume is and they still can't
keep up with the volume and there's
nothing worse than being unemployed and
nervous about a paycheck and then you
call for unemployment benefits and you
can't get through on the phone I get it
I get it and we have a thousand people
working on it we have Google working on
it we have all these experts working on
it but they've been trying to bring up a
system again that did a much much lower
capacity this is 100 times or whatever
we've ever done before the good news is
this you're going to get the same
benefit anyway it's not like it's
costing you money right I know it's
frustrating but once you qualify you're
the
qualification is retroactive so you're
going to get the same benefit it's not
costing you any money it's not being
that because you couldn't make the call
today it means you're not going to get
the benefit you will get the benefit
it's just an annoying delay and believe
me people are working seven days a week
on it let's take one more what is the
timetable for that and what will it take
for you to say okay we've got enough
data open up this particular region okay
there are no committees here this is
we've always talked about the economy of
the state in terms of different regions
Manhattan is not Buffalo let's use that
same regional template when we talk
about reopening let's look at the
numbers for that region on the kovat
virus let's look at the hospitalization
rate are we on the ascent on we are we
on the descent
are we on the plateau for that region
hospital capacity for that region
infection rate for that region and then
let's make be open to making a region by
region determination right so look at
that region who does that the state does
that working with the local governments
that's it there is no new committee here
there's no new process it's just you yes
lieutenant governor Kathy hoechlin
western New York will be not just
focusing on that decision it's more the
when in the how right let's take western
New York when do you reopen it like all
these governors in all these states are
trying to figure out when well look at
the data look at the hospitalization
rate look at the infection rate and tell
me where you are
are you the unsent plateau the descent
CDC has guidelines you have to be stable
or declining for two weeks look at the
CDC guidelines
talk to the local officials the when is
data-driven not when do you want
questions one do you want my answer is I
wanted yesterday okay it's not what you
want it's data-driven right so look at
the data
Kathy Huckle will coordinate that with
the local officials and then I think the
better question is and when we reopen
what did we learn and what can we how do
we reimagine western New York to be the
better for it and what what lessons do
we want to take forward when we do the
reopening and then on the reopening how
do we phase it what businesses first do
we do it by percentages let's talk about
all of that so it's the it's the when
and the how data-driven on the when not
political pressure on the wind well
people are yelling at me I want to open
because I don't want to take the
political heat if you don't want to take
the political heat you shouldn't be in
the political kitchen which is called
being an elected official in the state
of New York I have to get to Washington
thank you guys thank you there's no
state money in that right now do you
have hope that could change by the time
they vote on it I think it's a terrible
mistake not to provide funding for the
states I gets more businesses I get
airlines
how about police how about fire how
about health care workers
how about teachers you we're not going
to fund schools I don't get it I don't
get it that's why I'm not in Washington
thank you very much guys